alors n'hésitez pas à mettre une note
bien sûr un cyril hanouna avec le ca de
la personne derrière bien entendu et
pour les moniteurs qui sont dans le
public non un restau verso mais non
parce que j'ai l'honneur par nortel à
cela c'est qu'on joue pas mais resterait
ce que tu as mis en enchères mais je
préfère d'abord devant moi que derrière
c'est comme matthew barnaby n'est pas
admis en cours pas d'accord il avait
déjà fait un chroniqueur venir à son
conseil de classe avec son portail ban
actuellement
si vous avez déjà vu un chroniqueur
rentrer chez eux je traque des pmp cyril
les cherry pour ceux qui sont depuis on
choisissait un délégué de classe qui
donnera son appréciation également pour
les chroniqueurs savoie l'année initiale
koné qui vous voulez alors donc vous
lire magnéto me concerne un module et
oui tout à fait magnéto mais bon oui je
m'appelle de faire ça tu vas te calmer
la lonab à jubiler martin et moi le
malin et c'est parti pour le conseil de
classe du prof principal babar
[Applaudissements]
un chef qui montre chaque jour qu'il
sait tenir sa classe aussi bien en
plateau quand rigide
oui mais c'est les sont dehors merci les
gars donc merci au régime je viens de
passer ces je viens sur la tête de ma
mère
j'arrête l'émission mais tu vas
retourner nrj12 baba un prof qui a du
mal à trouver sa came niveau meuf je
suis sûr aucun délire et pas seulement
dans la classe sur la planète entière
aucune femme ne semble avoir les faveurs
de baba le tombeur des lits d'arrêt pas
du tout est lié
j'adore et dégouline magnifier sais pas
mais c'est salut moi c'est pas mon
délire mais à vous et à votre façon à
arrêter
et s'il ya bien une chose que baba
maîtrise à la perfection c'est les
vannes et les punchline il ya treize
prix nobel qui ont étudié des choses
dans la mer sont pas là métal et même
temps les mêmes trucs que kelly sûr que
toi ça marche c'est quoi ce pirate en
avant dans l'aspirateur donc demain à la
maison aucune matière à l'inversé si la
plupart des professeurs utilisent le
bescherelle comme livre référence cyril
quant à lui préfère le ba ba sh réel un
manuel avec un vocabulaire un peu
différentes compétences mbarga mbarga je
vous explique la nar ya de quoi la
reconnaissez lara sera on nous envoyait
deuxième choisi de vous un peu plus
rares l'étape mais ba ba c'est surtout
un cardio au top entretenue grâce à des
heures de danse chaque jour dans
l'émission
la fage année j'ai décidé de me classer
ce soir je n'a
c'est moi
[Musique]
alors quelle note pour baba
avec ces la note de la saison alors
c'est moi qui ai dit donna parle je vais
commencer à donner à par l'ofii je fais
demande et donc on va vers valérie
bénaïm alesi rêve où commencer par la
plus gentille et vous avez raison
voilà pas l'air comme ça non est ce que
je voulais j'avais envie de vous
défoncer je vous le dis voilà ça
t'arrive tourné maire de malade et j'ai
commencé à réfléchir sur votre carte et
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait je
vous aime vraiment beaucoup mais
vraiment beaucoup et qu'en plus alors
voilà vous pouvez avoir la caméra ce que
vous dessinez c'est la nana
non je vous le dis maintenant instamment
vous montrer à la caméra ce que vous
venez de dessiner et montrez moi c'est
une fusée assez compliqué mais bien oui
donc plus d'avoir la confirmation de ce
que j'avais envie de dire oh bien sûr
ouais bien sûr vous êtes complètement
dingue mais ce qui pourrait être un
immense défaut est en fait une qualité
et vous avez compris et vous avez
compris qu'il faut cultiver ses défauts
pour en faire des qualités et que les
gens fini finissent par vous aimé pour
ce que vous êtes et dans votre entièreté
et donc vous vous êtes complètement
dingue
vous avez un gros problème de 2,2
de quoi de vous canaliser ce que vous
êtes vous êtes dans la rose est un
d'histrion sûr c'est un mot rayons on
croit que vous n'êtes pas un bosseur
acharné mais vous êtes un bosseur
acharné qui est en même temps capable de
tout défaire une émission de pont
pendant l'émission elle-même
voilà vous demander beaucoup aux équipes
l'on sait des choses à lui dire elle
n'est pas d'animal que le temps est par
ailleurs petit mot à titre personnel
puisque vous avez été mon producteur
également sur sur la télé et vous avez
été un très bon producteur est vraiment
et je voulais vous en remercier ce que
vous avez dit des choses très
intéressantes et très importantes en
début d'année qui m'ont beaucoup aidé
ça joue ça on arrête les missions ces
noms là maintenant la télé gentillet
choses sérieuses il faut arrêter de dire
aux invités qui sont dans votre top 3
dès qu'il ya une animatrice dans le top
3 de vos animatrice préférée dès que
c'est un animateur c'est pareil dixinn
non car plusieurs un grand coeur non non
excusez moi ça s'appelle qui s'appelle
allez pouvoir était d'être lèche cul on
n'allait jamais les chocs un cul de
vouloir mettre des trucs dans le clip de
tout le monde non mais c'est vrai dans
ton cul dans le cube
les gens ne sont plus ou si vous n'avez
pas les expressions faciales
malgré tout et comme je vous ai ma forme
aux mots que vous êtes un excellent
finisseur et un animateur absolument
bluffant je vous ai mis un accent cas du
cartable alors on a on a on a trois
minutes on m'a laissé isabelle tout ce
qu'elle a dit est vrai notamment
l'histoire dans le cul elle en fera
mentir me disent ça mais c'est pas le
thème de la soirée
vous voulez vous mettre 10 mai je me
suis souvenu que certains trucs dedans
moi pour ma part comparé sans m'avoir
vercingétorix alors que je m'arrête à
l'apollon trois mois pour avoir sans
cesse répété que tous mes ex était mort
lorsqu'on a la moitié seulement huit
mois ça pouvait avoir fait friser avec
de l'eau alors vous savez que ça me
défrise justement pour le chocolat parce
que moi je l'aurais mieux prix cvt et du
chocolat blanc j'aime pas le noir plus à
refaire la créativité de sales gosses
plus pour les super de cuiseaux même si
c'est surtout votre mère qu'il faut
féliciter et en fait moi parce que c'est
pas moi que ça profite donc si on
additionne tout ça mais ça nous fait 5
sur 10
j'aime
elle a bien bossé isaac bravo il a chéri
christine quitte alors tout d'abord tu
veux redire alors on va meilleur danseur
meilleur animateur de la décennie
meilleur homme de coeur et ça je le dis
depuis au moins dix ans que je vous
connais bien avant d'être dans votre
émission
est ce que j'ai apprécié aussi avec vous
c'est le fait que les gens viennent
comme le disait raymond total à frapper
à votre porte pour parler au peuple
français
ça c'est très important et ça veut dire
qu'on sait absolument qui vous êtes j'ai
très très rapide tu comme aux chamois
votre michel mer jaune aux éditeurs il
est juste jaloux parce que je vous adore
mon cher cyril lamotte j'adore votre
coeur parce que personne d'autre dans le
pas et son corps tu l'as en fout non non
je m'en fous de son corps honnêtement
j'aime pas sa coupe de cheveux en
revanche mais son coeur gênerait
personne d'autre qu'à un couvre-feu
comme aulas pour tous à votre coeur je
vous donne un affinement le bal des faux
culs ce conseil
on commence par les points forts bayer
oui on appelle moi je préfère laisser ça
aux autres
vous avez quand même quelques qualités
c'est à nu franchement intelligence plus
que d'habitude quoi innovation et
fluidité fluidité gestuelle et fluidité
dans l'expression et croyez moi c'est
une denrée très peu partagé pour cent et
félicite mais cyril vous avez eu
énormément de points faibles
vous n'avez été que trois fois meilleur
que les autres animateurs et cette année
la couvrance été ridicule je vais pas
citer les noms des autres mais
maintenant vous auriez dû être bien
meilleur ensuite vous avez été trois
fois trop gentil je vous l'avais déjà
dit les crs et donc vous vous
ramollissez mais ça c'est le pouvoir
c'est la gloire
voulez-vous maintenir mais non cyril
retenue vous même redonné agression
revenez méchant et vous aurez peut-être
meilleure note gary terminerions oui
mais ça va la mesure aboli il m'est
arrivé à bien des choses qui vous êtes
arrière un boxeur monsieur bourgeois 0
qui le 98,3 mais oui je suis d'accord
défoncé castaldi
ça va repartir non mais franchement je
dois terminer sur une note positive
parce que c'est la soirée positive n'en
revenons un peu d'eau l'année prochaine
il y aura trois parties dans touche pas
à mon poste est pour moi pour les
spectateurs pour les chroniqueurs pour
les téléspectateurs
ce sera trois fois plus de plaisir donc
pour tout ça et pour tout l'amour que je
vous porte
je vous mets un sublime 3
géraldine ou kelly comme vous voulez
géraldine vous êtes sûr est ce que vous
aimez des andouillettes les
andouillettes chez basse piano déjà les
andouilles vous avez fait une année
d'andouillette en fait alors
andouillettes ca a cédé andouillette de
très bonne qualité
ah ouais alors il ya une première partie
vous avez commencé anxieux agité début
d'année c'est toujours effroyable pour
vous parce que nouveau nouveaux
conducteurs nouvelles productions
nouveaux chroniqueurs nouveaux entrants
nouveaux sortants nouvelle audimat
énorme stress on sentait sa suite et une
deuxième partie pour moi alors ceni
d'arcania sera j'invente heras cas où le
social est un salon est on passé cet
invité sûreté pmp voilà je partage
complètement la vie et christine et de
raymond c'était très émouvant c'est très
fort c'était évidemment on en parlera
dans encore 20 ans et puis troisième
partie alors là c'était l'apothéose pour
moi février l'apothéose sort de feu
d'artifice tort de jerry lewis du paf
que dans l'impro que des fulgurances
toujours drôle nadine et comme roque fou
rire car faite donc c'était magistral
mais elle a bien résumé la dèche et pour
ça je suis toujours là toujours les mots
juste magnifique 700 chez vous faire
très bon troisième trimestre enfin très
bon troisième trimestre soit une tribune
alors faut faire attention parce que si
on rate les deux promis sa rivale pour
fait pas vraiment raté c'était moyen
alors ta droite qualité dvd bonsoir
alors si ray bonsoir vous êtes un ex
idée de la vie à plusieurs points
communs il est insupportable
ça nous fait aussi un petit point commun
ça m'arrive de temps en temps moins de
vous mais ça m'arrive
pour les points positifs
j'ai été super heureuse de passer une
deuxième année à votre à vos côtés quand
vous faites des promesses vous les tenez
et ça c'est une qualité qui est assez
rare quand vous dites à une personne ne
vous lâche pas vous lâchez pas
j'aimerais donc pour ça j'aurais voulu
vous mettre un 10 sur 10 mais comme
d'autres d'ailleurs encore encore et
encore travailler vos dépassements sur
terre battue un joli 9 sur 10 je saurai
qui vous a dit ça
[Rires]
oui bonsoir bonsoir les sportifs le
savent
le plus dur dans le marathon c'est une
allure constante et moi je trouve que
vous avez été constant et ça depuis des
années pour pour les fans qui vous
suivent ils le savent vous êtes à fond
depuis des années vous êtes le beau
mélange entre le fiston le gendre idéal
bardon est un peu l'enfant terrible
acquis au final on ne peut rien on ne
peut rien reprocher tel vote roja est
grande sa on vous l'avait déjà dit et ce
qui est intéressant chez vous comparez à
deux animateurs c'est les regards caméra
et bat beaucoup d'animateurs qui font
des vrais regard caméra et les gens
derrière leur quinze de ces pour eux et
c'est ça qui est beau voilà il ya deux
événements qui m'ont vraiment marqué
cette année c'était la grande régalade
de noël ah ouais c'était juste
magnifique
j'ai félicité pour ça c'était vraiment
très très beau et puis après quelque
chose qui m'a marqué bien sûr c'est la
grande race sera à wes et roger
d'ailleurs bravo était formidable rojo
après bon alors je vous mets pas la note
ultime
malgré tous ces compliments parce que
j'ai senti que depuis quelques mois
depuis les changements de numéros de
téléphone y avait une une genre de
brouille de connexion entre nous et je
sais aussi maintenant margot
go robbie m'a sans doute dépassé donc
pour ça je vous enlève quelques points
et puis aussi dire que je pense être la
seule chroniqueuse qui n'a absolument
jamais dansé avec vous du coup je vous
mets la note de 8 alors je pars à bercy
sa fille tu proposes qu'après le conseil
de classe vous dansiez un petit peu mais
je vais vous dire j'adore delphine qui
est un amour de filles moi je m'en
allais lacets alors vraiment bon soir
alors où est cet objet
on n'est pas obligé de quoi c'est cissé
ne suis pas choqué je vais faire comme
valérie au début j'avais envie de vous
défoncer à la et je vais vous défoncer
quand même il faut arrêter les
survêtements en pyjama nous a fait peur
à ma mère arrêtez de dire mon frère
frérot même quand vous parlez ariza faut
arrêter de dire tu étais mon pote tu es
mon copain j'appelle tout le monde ma
mère à la calculer si vous enlevez tous
à l'émergence et à 20h53 les cheveux
jaune poussin faut arrêter aussi vous
avez plus de 18 ans voire 1000 à +18
enfin chelsea tout ça les conneries ça à
nouveau arrêté nos appels
chroniqueur au brief une forme brief
bonjour ping pong
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sérieux ce soir faut faire des
émissions les gens méritent l'émission
fléchettes
je vais passer aux choses un peu plus
sympa ça veut dire inventer des
séquences personne le fait le dernier
celui qui faisait ça c'était christophe
dechavanne avec rien du tout on a vu une
fois avec le buzz sur la tête de kelly
on dirait en direct pendant deux heures
je l'aï déjà dit j'ai découvert un cyril
mois malgré les coups de pression vers
le mois de décembre novembre janvier de
gens haut placés qui lui ont dit ils
invitent plus ces gens là ne fait plus
et j'en ris je ferai quand même et si
vous n'êtes pas content c'est pareil
pour ça je t'aime pour ça cette force
parce que résister aux pressions des
gars qui t'ont appelez moi je serais
déjà parti au guatemala je vais te
mettre ainsi ce parce que 35 euros
l'émission s'est passé et frais
[Applaudissements]
alors honnêtement cyril pour pour moi
vous êtes fascinant parce que vous êtes
un spectacle et quand on vous regarde on
apprend beaucoup et j'ai appris beaucoup
c'était pour le côté un peu sus boules
de ma demain notation punitif ce qui est
très énervant agaçant avec vous c'est
que toute votre immense talent et dieu
seul sait qu'il est important et est
grand et ben vous le cacher parce que
vous ne travaillez pas les émissions
parce que vous découvrez les émulsions
alors est-ce que vous inventez les
propos de l'invité c'est vrai mais avec
un aplomb maxime n'est pas un chiffre et
bien vous lamenter vous n'avez pas là et
ça ça me fascine c'est vrai que j'avais
pas trop bête comme notes et blague à
part a beau côté j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses et l'heure limites plus j'ai
appris une chose essentielle que je
n'avais pas en télévision ça s'appelle
osez donc je vais oser cyril et je vous
mets 0
[Applaudissements]
alors oui maxi hors-série là chaque soir
vous proposer avec votre énergie un show
un vrai show là où certains passerait
des heures à lire un prompteur vous pas
besoin rien et écrit débarqué à vous les
faites vous les vivez et vous nous
emporter vous êtes un peu un magicien
vous êtes mon david copperfield et vous
savez à quel point j'adore ça
alors vous êtes exigeants envers vous
même avec nous mais divertir est un art
et franchement ça travaille alors peu
mieux que la première et vous chaque
soir c'est une leçon
alors ma note l état sppe et réparé
cette saison
vous m 19.19 saison mais à vous savez
vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire
pour la 10e olala c'est mon maximum et
clément d'antibes
il a compris la séquence oui oui il a
compris la mauvaise compétition donne un
mauvais 1 cela sur la réussite que son
proche vouloir avoir raison et de gagny
ce qui peut et comment faire la
différence entre une banane et une
orange
la mauvaise compétition la mange des
comportements barbares
le système de compétition est très
archaïque
tu l'as dit tout à l'heure il ya des
personnes qui font des choses pas bien
mais il n'y a personne qui n'est pas
bien il ya des bilans négatifs qui
sortent sur lui mais personne ne sait le
bien qu'il peut faire de son côté alors
faire un croche patte à quelqu'un pour
qu'il tombe il faut pas faire cela allez
je te souhaite je vous souhaite à tous
de réussir
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce disent ah oui papa tu es
responsable botté par alain bernard
responsable
même quand tu poses toi si tu sais pas
si tu as un micro pour l'état c'est rien
c'est une fille alors moi t'aimons tu
agis ni pour mathias génie voilà pour
moi tu es un génie telle jt non ça c'est
la télé voilà et de matar est j'arrête
ah ouais merci alors l'adorent
et il a exercé mes jambes me mon chéri
bien sûr mais ce que je t'attendais
tellement bas je me rasseoir je vais
fermer ma gueule jean-yves hazoume jouer
dira surtout déjà que il a fallu que je
me batte jusqu'à la fin d'après midi que
vous écris parce que je refusais de me
prêter à cette mascarade que j'estime
qu'on ne vote pas pour quelqu'un comme
vous ou mérite pas notre estomac d'un
voté pour mozart assorti d'un opéra elle
tenait à donner une note à louis pasteur
puis la vente et le 25 à 10 quand les
dés sont dits sûrs c'est la parole
chantée tatayous car on sait toutes ces
raisons voilà je ne vous ne serez pas je
ne serais pas le bréviaire de toutes vos
qualités de ce que nous avait tellement
vous arrêterez-vous trop long voilà on
m'a obligé à mettre une note
évidemment je mets 10 et j'avance que je
n'adresse serait plus à part le concept
ans à tous ceux qui me sont blessés une
manne une note inférieure à celle ci
[Applaudissements]